to see what made red robo such an
important figure given that he vanished
from public life 30 years ago and yet
we're still talking about him well
because of the great drama of British
Leyland that occupied us throughout the
70s and a bit of the 80s a company which
was British owned had 40% of the market
and stood as kind of symbol of of
British good manufacturing and it's
slowly and then they quickly went to
pieces and many people blamed the
union's for being really involved with
that and read Robbo as the leader of the
of the union's for five years was was
was fingered for it the interesting
thing is he was probably the most
notorious trade unionist of the 1970s he
wasn't actually a union leader he was
only a convener at Longbridge yes I mean
he wasn't he wasn't a national leader
but he was very important for the
British Leyland shop stewards and I mean
he was the person who more or less had
to say about whether workers would agree
to the very striking program of
retrenchment and renewal which famous
Sir Michael Edwards put in at the first
he was in favor at least part of it
because he was a communist and the
Communists believed in state ownership
and they believed in making it work so
he went along with some of the early
Edwards plans on the basis that it would
be consultation with the workers but
when Edwards got to the stage where he
wanted to dismiss 25,000 people and
close 13 factories he got it through by
forcing a vote of the of the workforce
but Robinson felt that was too much and
he objected to it and Edwards used that
as a way to to get rid of him because he
wanted to get the first new car that led
him that produced
ages the Metro up and running and he was
advised by his his people at Longbridge
which was the biggest Leyland plant that
with all the disputes that might break
out they couldn't guarantee it and
Edwards his reaction was to was was to
sack Robinson and Robinson was not super
short on time Tommy enough by his own
Union I mean there was a strike yes
Massa my briefly lowest riders and
mostly lemma trustees today said he was
unfairly maligned by the media was he
very briefly he was made into much more
of a bogeyman than he then and he was he
was a much more substantial man than his
his end suggested all right Martin Agni
appreciate you joining us and thanks for
joining us on that trip down memory lane